time for a pep talk
you are awesome and you can do even more
than you think you can
if you don't believe me listen to this
inspirational human
hello there drew i am tabitha brown
and i wanted to give a little bit of
encouragement if that is okay
i understand that we're living in some
tough times right now right
it's some very heavy um
and sad times for a lot of people but i
want to encourage and remind
everyone that this is a temporary moment
the sadness the heaviness it will pass
and i know sometimes it feels like we're
never going to get through but we will
together we will and listen even in the
midst of all this stuff
happening you can still pursue your
dreams do not get defeated
do not be discouraged all right it's
gonna be okay
and you will still weed you just have to
keep going
hi drew i'm pamela peeps from the
friendly fridge um
the friendly fridge is a community-run
community-owned
fridge which literally means there's a
fridge
on the street that anyone can take food
from or leave food
i started the friendly fridge during the
pandemic
like anyone else i was seeing lines
sneaking around grocery stores
food pantries soup kitchens we got a
fridge donated
plugged it in wrote free food on the
side
in spanish and english and immediately
people started
using it the fridges are all over the
country
and all over the world really and it
continues to grow
every day there's so many of us out
there that want to
connect and want to help each other it's
restored my faith
and my own power and the power that we
all have
to do something that will truly make an
impact
hey guys it's billy eichner my piece of
advice
is basically about persistence
uh when i was trying to make it in
entertainment
i got a lot of no's a lot of rejection
which is far for the course
uh but if you really want it you just
have to keep going you can't take no for
an answer
and you have to keep proving yourself
and
just keep at it you know and at least
that way you won't regret having not
tried doing it in the first place i
think that if you're doing anything in a
creative field you just have to say yes
to everything
you have to be opportunistic here at the
show we've always just tried to do the
most
with what we have and it's taken us a
long way
don't get too far out in front of
yourself don't set your expectations too
high
don't be too low when you're
disappointed just make the thing
then make the next thing then make the
next thing and as you lay these bricks
eventually you have a wall and
eventually you have a home
stay committed do it because you love it
and make something
that makes people happier can i keep it
real with you
if you're unable to genuinely root for
others while they're winning then don't
be surprised if no one roots for you
see naturally people support those who
they see supporting others
and giving back you will always reap
what you sow
so so love so support so
kindness and you will get those back
thank you for that wise advice i feel
[Music]
inspired